hi hey hello excuse me is this where we
check in for the red car hitting me I
can't talk to you right now all good
it's my first red carpet Chinese yeah
seriously the big league brother oh no
no man please I haven't seen a teenage
girl go nuts like that does Elle Fanning
cook Kevin in the bother that's a great
junket which was so awesome I just don't
want to be that guy that pisses off
celebrities for please hey Diane what
the can I check in you don't move
I'll catch up with you soon Hollywood
all of us out bright shiny new people
where the am i Access Hollywood
somebody else I don't care I don't know
I don't know who that is local a mine in
Siberia here or what you guys know I am
right you seen my cooking show without
Roker salt and pepper can you please
check again it's Brian but lemon with
the download another way over capacity I
don't know what you think this is but
it's not some farm that's but you roll
up into it still my face for your thank
you oh she's really talking back to mr.
two million click superstore and don't
all right I do not feel good about that
and it's three million actually
this thing's already started Britney's
found her way to the red carpet she in
the movie no she just appears wherever
there's cameras good luck
he didn't even talk to anybody no I'm
not actually in the movie but I had to
come out and support my girl it's
Melissa McCarthy and Kristen Bell who
are as essential to me as my fierce
water that's 50% more h h3o makes it
much Britney when we come back the
actual stars of the boss when we return
nice to see you Britney got it we're
good yeah you owe me for that one that
was
dude are you excited to see dinklage
peter dinklage is not coming he's
shooting that wizard show
my here this is an actual
nightmare can I talk to your manager
do you have great job with Chloe Moretz
great thank you
wait you did that interview I saw that
and with the downloader that's what I've
been saying yes it's actually just
watching the remix never going to be
taken seriously again sure I can squeeze
you in somewhere never learn to speak up
for yourself Byron come on wave a sub
rookie hey Kevin how are you good man
how you doing buddy Nuri I guess they
found a spot for me over here you know
you're ahead of me yeah I don't know
look I'm sorry I should probably get to
my spot you have a good carpet okay
well son you and me when I interviewed
for Kevin's Java that no way today we're
on his way out haven't officially
announced it but who are they gonna give
it to you come on for it so Lyons you're
hysterical really why I gotta stand up
have a good carpet I mean what an
asshole all right let's do this
here we go in three two one
I'm here at the world premiere of the
boss where we are bringing you all the
action welcome to the star-studded
premiere of bossy boss why you doing
that let's get you all the buzz buzz
buzz what's name of the movie all right
boss three two one
that you think
okay she sort of counteracts the crazy
of militias up there I'm sorry what are
we talking about here it means to me you
know you're my partner okay when am I
gonna get my money guys let you up right
here you know that right in front of all
these way
is this movie really about female
empowerment tell me about that I noticed
some of you don't have your camera's out
so the nameplate
what's it like was it fun was it great
are you family
will you see him again no was that your
question
Thanks Oh Kristen Bell everybody how are
you I'm here with Kristen Bell who looks
ravishing
I always forget your last name its Bell
yeah
I always forget because you're in like
the top three Kristen's for me like the
Jennifers I'm always confused no Kristen
come back here Kristen you know what
this sounds like this sounds like you're
firing me it's really funny I am fired
oh okay okay
in this town to keep my job yeah
you